what's there between this cephalo metric  x-ray and a panoramic x-ray the painter  Maxim x-ray it x-rays your boat and the  other one x-rays your teeth th and DL  and das orthodontist I'm a dentist you  checked your teeth and your orthodontist  you Street in your teeth how much does  it cost to go to school to be an  orthodontist okay like 13 bucks but I  don't glass rubber stem the special glue  would be literally when people are like  sad or mad and you just smile and I help  them feel better  you look healthy and zombies Club great  smiles who's the last one you said spit  sucker a skyscraper Kapow  but they have a bit mouth regards  laziness looks like a tiny fork though  what if somebody told you like well I  can do your braces like just come to my  house and I'll do them I'll rather go to  the orthodontist one kids are scared you  help them and you say it's okay I know  missing a tooth  are you ready to be an orthodontist  [Music]